[Music]
good morning Hank what's today say
Tuesday
it's February 2nd now April 2nd what is
Monday good morning Hank it's Monday
April 2nd I'm standing here in the
ramble in Central Park our answer to the
state of Montana Hank I'd like to show
you the difference between your
wilderness in Montana and our wilderness
here in New York the Yeti and I were
walking happily along through the ramble
when we came across you guessed it porn
I'm going to have to shoot this at a
wide angle so we don't offend our
younger viewers but trust me it's very
dirty Hank I've been walking through the
ramble trying to think of your
punishment it's been hard
all the nerdfighters have had such great
suggestions I just don't know which one
to pick
I think I'll let you choose your own
punishment well from a list of five
broadly speaking I think there are two
kinds of punishments embarrassment slash
humiliation punishments and pain
punishments so far we've tended to
emphasize pain punishments because pain
is funny but humiliation is also funny
so my first suggestion is that you
attend to senior water aerobics class
I'm sure they have one at the YMCA in
Missoula they do have a YMCA don't that
option to have your chin waxed by a
professional option three act out your
most embarrassing moment using hand
puppets note that had better be one
embarrassing moment Hank I don't want
you cheating me if you're going to do
that punishment it had better be every
bit as embarrassing as waxing your chin
would be painful option for convinced
people in downtown Missoula to sing
verses from the nerdfighters song with
you okay for option five I'm going to
get up close to a goose I'm scared of
geese but it's gonna be awesome
scare
option five visit your local GM dealer
and test drive a Hummer I hope you enjoy
your punishment I'll see you tomorrow oh
and I've got a message for all you free
Hank people you want a free Hank if 20
people give $10 to the foundation to
decrease worldsuck
Hank doesn't have to do a punishment at
all